[Music]
hello and welcome to another wolfram
tech talk i'm arben calzici and today i
will be talking to john woodard the ceo
of wolfram blockchain labs they'll be
telling us a bit about what they've been
getting up to for the last year hi john
have you been
pretty good thanks for having me
so yeah it's pretty exciting to talk
about a lot of the stuff we've been
doing at wolf from blockchain labs or
as we like to say because that
name is definitely a mouthful just wbl
so we've been working on many of the
things that we worked on since our
exception
and that has to do with
integrating blockchains with our
blockchain integration
computational facts
and those are delivered through oracles
to smart contracts
blockchain analytics
and then blockchain education
and it's really been exciting the past
year because we've not only added a ton
of collaborators that we're working with
and have others that were
in
negotiations with
but have kind of expanded a little bit
and also started working on
nft
related projects as well
so just to kind of go back and recap a
little bit
blockchain integrations are what we call
when we host nodes from different
blockchain networks and then integrate
access to that blockchain or
in some cases a distributed ledger which
is kind of a larger category to the wolf
language
and that allows you to both read
information from that ledger and in this
case what we mean by reading is you can
read
transactions that is that the transfer
of one of coins from one account to
another account um and then also smart
contracts that may
um
be run
on the ledger
and
do
both transactions but then other
programmatic um interactions between um
different things
um
so let's say let's say you have you know
the ethereum blockchain right
let's say you know just for the sake of
a hypothetical here that i'm very
ignorant about how all of this works
um so you're saying that this blockchain
is integrated with the wolfram language
insofar as i can read transactions uh on
this blockchain
what else can i do
in terms of like integration of the
wolfram language with various
blockchains so
can i make transactions on here or
or yeah absolutely so
you can go with the latest which that
we've done which is cardano
um by the time this comes out
we should have documentation right now
it's already available
in wolfram language
um but what you can do is both read the
transactions
as you discuss and then also write
transactions
and transfers as well
so
um
those
transfers of
coins
you can do in a programmatic
fashion which makes it a little bit
easier um to do on a large scale than if
you were sitting at your computer kind
of
through a centralized exchange or even
decentralized exchange trying to do them
kind of by hand by keyboard right so you
can just have a notebook open and if you
have some sequence of transactions that
you need to do
or if you have some scheduled
transactions you need to do maybe that's
easier than you know working through
some kind of standard graphical user
interface on like coinbase or something
like that
yeah exactly exactly
um
and that makes it way easier and then
you can also kind of interact
which also makes it easier for
large numbers of transactions and you
can imagine that
as uh
crypto
um
[Music]
both
um
[Music]
native coins and then also what they
call stable coins which are
coins that are backed generally on a
one-to-one basis with
um
some
central bank currency
um
you can do things like you could do
payroll and rather than have it be you
know sitting there
at uh
you know your favorite centralized
exchange doing things you know
mouse click by mouse click
you can just run a program in their
reform notebook and
you know go out for lunch and then come
back and everything could be done
yeah it seems like it would be pretty
easy to actually manage you know
something like that is set up
yeah exactly so
the blockchain integration in many ways
facilitates the construction of more
complex
programs
and one of the things that's exciting
for us is we've expanded that in a
couple different ways one is that we've
worked now on oracle services which will
be coming out
very soon like within like weeks
um
rather than uh so that's coming out
within weeks and then we also
will expand across the board to most of
the blockchains that we support with
oracle services with our computational
facts
so it's kind of that's one thing that
we've talked about you know since
um
we came
out kind of as an entity and now that's
come to fruition so it's like when you
kind of look at the four kind of areas
that we've talked about previously we're
just checking the boxes and these things
are coming out and being available for
developers to use blockchains to use and
the larger
from community as well
i see and so you know forgive the
question perhaps but in this context
what do you mean by an oracle service
you mentioned computational facts so
you know a little context clue there
maybe is that is an oracle service
something where you can kind of look up
you know verified answers to something
that have been stored on the blockchain
or
what does that have to do with you know
how does that integrate with this
yeah so i think
it's kind of exciting in many ways
because
there are two ways that you can kind of
think about
um
interacting
one is that if you have a smart contract
that's going to be run on a blockchain
say
on cardano with their their plutus smart
contract framework
it
needs information from the outside world
to be able to be to do
to have more functionality because
what's
a blockchain is almost like its own
universe and only has access to the
things that exist there
so
um an oracle which is unfortunately
named
um
actually takes information from the
outside world and pulls information it's
kind of the total inverse of what i was
thinking yes exactly which is part of
the problem with the name because it's
very confusing
so
one of the things that we have as an
advantage at wolfram is hey we've been
working on
making data computer computable not only
data in general but authoritative data
for the past you know
15 plus years since from alpha kind of
started in its infancy
as a skunk works project
under another name which it's still
talked about in the company at times
which is kind of funny um
which i won't say
which is kind of interesting i suppose
yeah i wonder if it's called challenge i
don't think it's public i don't think
it's public knowledge i think
steven has kind of talked about it
before
um and i'm certain that other people
have talked about it
and
there's nothing like
sinister about it but i just won't say
it so people have to go look it up and
find it now it sounds a lot more
sinister
yes it was um but we have this that
we've done for like quite some time and
so we have this distinct advantage
because we have
um
all of these
entities about the world and can talk
about the world in wolfram language and
provide those representations on chain
as well
uh to these different smart contract
frameworks
so our computational facts are really
all about that so it's really exciting
to see that that will be in use soon and
then we'll be expanding
um
because so many chains are really
interested in that okay i think i think
this makes sense to me so the you know
what this uh oracle service is doing is
it's connecting
smart contracts that exist on the
blockchain to this outside world via the
framework that powers wool from alpha so
it has access to things like historical
knowledge or
current
weather conditions i don't know what
sort of smart contract might need that
but i can you know imagine there are
cases where that might be possible
yeah exactly so i like to think about
them as computational facts in a way
because you're not just interested in
the like
historical things or real-time things
itself but
in the future you can imagine
taking combinations of those things to
come up with bespoke
you know
units that you need within a smart
contract because you're really going to
want to crunch it down so you'll not
only need like you know maybe some
historical information some real-time
information but you also need
algorithmic information to do and
deliver
some specific
calculated unit that then is going to
help you make a decision on chain um you
can imagine that with like the weather
example that you know
whether it's this weird thing where
you can kind of use weather for very
simple decisions in ways right but like
it's kind of cloudy here in iowa city i
don't know what it's like in champaign
but
okay so it's like hey
do we need an umbrella like if we're
gonna go outside right like and you kind
of need maybe that decision or maybe
what should you wear like should you
wear a jacket does it need to be
waterproof do you need to wear
galoshes i didn't think that i was going
to say that
certainly in this interview
the only mention of the word in any of
the tech talks
right right i had to pull it out um
so
it's kind of like
you need that information to make those
types of decisions but that's on a
really basic you know basis like does it
really matter if it's you know
five
uh degrees fahrenheit or a couple
degrees centigrade off probably not does
it matter like how much rain there's
going to be
you know like if it's a couple inches
versus maybe you know
six seven inches
which is a lot obviously but like
probably you know not unless you're like
really concerned about where you're
driving or you know where you're you're
located then it makes sense but those
decisions you don't need like precise
information but then you can think about
other other situations that are going to
be the situations that are more
important smart contract wise where
you'll need
very precise information about
whether or other real-time data or
historical information
in a certain context to make a decision
say if you were trying to plant at a
specific time right then you might want
a lot of historical information to
contextualize the the forecasts
that are going to be available and then
you may have that backed also by
something that's called parametric
insurance that can actually pay you in
real time
um based on
the weather
in kind of what could potentially be a
programmatic kind of fashion
and that could be again if you're a
farmer and say you make a decision based
on both historical weather information
and forecasted weather information
in again like your specific area where
it becomes really important to know
what weather stations you may be using
or have some combination of weather
stations
to look at a specific area
but what if it doesn't happen like you
you thought it was going to happen and
now you need to make adjustments and you
need money to be able to make those
adjustments parametric insurance is all
about that and that's one of these areas
that's really would potentially expand
with
blockchain-based smart contracts and
blockchain-based insurance and the
reason why goes back to what you
originally said arvin about being able
to access things programmatically well
you wouldn't want to have to call your
your insurance agent or someone else to
get that kind of small payout
um you just want to have that small
payout appear in your account and be
able to act on that so it could be that
um
because
you know things have changed with the
weather you need to make some sort of
adjustment maybe you need to pull out um
the um
i guess
the sprinklers i know that they have
them
they're not sprinklers but i guess
they're agricultural sprinklers i should
know this because like
this is embarrassing
yeah maybe that that sounds that sounds
much better than like sprinklers wow
sounds a little more a little more
professional maybe in the farming
context yes but you know what i'm
talking like
like they have that arc and they're like
really like wheels maybe every
um five or ten meters that hold them up
and they use them for like sod and other
like high
like value kind of crops
um but you can imagine something like
that and um
needing access to the water and
everything else that you're going to do
well you need that that insurance payout
immediately to go out and
and start to do that or you need those
resources available immediately so
computational facts i like to think
about in that context
that
they'll they're important both from like
a historical side a real time side a
forecasting side an algorithmic side and
people are going to want to think about
them
per
the
smart contract and project that they're
working on and adjust them on that basis
because the weather and the thresholds
that are important to you
for your crop may be very different for
me and my crop or in the case of the
spectrum that we talked about very
different from like a farmer making a
decision on whether versus me making a
decision on do i where do i
know where my
right
okay that makes sense i can see how that
would be useful and you know how access
to all this information to be
pretty
really expand the kind of uh
options you have available when making
these sorts of contracts
yeah exactly so it's exciting that we we
will
be
launching that imminently
um
and go from kind of
just a
developer kind of mode where it's on
test then to gradually
working on things that will go live on
mainnet and
pushing that across different chains
which should be really exciting because
there's been a lot built up to that
we now host you know so many different
nodes from different blockchains that
are working on more it's just exciting
to see that phase um
like being initiating that phase okay
and it's not going to be coming out in
wolfram language 13.0 or is it not
exactly set yet
so
it's actually on a
its own
service so there may be some wolfram
language functions that
kind of arrive and are included
later
um maybe in the
in 0.1 or 0.2 kind of release
um
or like because we now also release our
own um updates it may come later but
it's likely to be as it's just owned
standalone
service okay um which is also you know
again like a really interesting and
useful thing because we have not
done that before and we're
just about
to do that like we're right on the
threshold so that's really exciting
um
so
yeah so i would go for that that's kind
of one thing and then the next thing
we're building on again these
integrations are blockchain analytics so
that's something where we've been
pressing and pressing and pressing and
pressing to get hardware because of the
cobit hardware shortage or i guess not
just i shouldn't say hardware i should
say like just chip
shortage in general
um
so that should be on the way very soon
and here like to this point
um
we've
with our blockchain integrations that
meant that you were interacting
almost
like most of the time almost directly
with the ledgers
so that we host
um
and we had started to database um
tokens
and
other smart contracts
and now we're going to accelerate that
process and do way more of that
to
speed up the interaction that people can
have um from wolfram language and make
even more analytics possible um so we
already have the ability and like zarya
uh has written some great posts on um
i think the dark side uh ransom i think
i remember having seen that yeah
yeah and then um christian has also
written on
some ethereum
[Music]
large scale
fees that were interesting
transaction wise so we've already
written about a number of interesting
blockchain analytics cases and showed
people how to use the blockchain
analytics as they exist now
and that's getting just
will get
better and more exciting and they'll be
more uses that people can can do with
our blockchain analytics
which is exciting as well so it's kind
of like again
across the board from the things that
we've like the four different areas that
we've talked about
um
more things are coming and more things
are coming very very soon
um
with that i'll also mention the fourth
thing for people who are counting
because they're like oh he's only
mentioned three things
blockchain educational stuff where
we've done
um a number of
um
workshops already this year which have
been exciting um
at
different uh universities
um so that's really been exciting um and
we
are
releasing some
videos
that are just more general and hopefully
we'll be able to release our larger
stuff um very soon so again like that's
been quite exciting with blockchain
educational stuff
in particular in this new area where
again we're building on top of our own
tools
um
building nfts or non-fungible tokens
a lot of the uses now have been about
collectibles
and that's seen a terrific amount of
excitement yeah right that's where i've
seen nfts popping up against you know
art collections primarily but i've
really seen you know what else they can
do so you want to give us a brief
overview of that
yeah sure so there are a lot of things
that nfts can do like not only um the
collectibles area which i think is this
really
um
behaviorally
like we like to i think collect things
as humans like
you know we collect experiences we
collect physical objects all all sorts
of stuff so i think there's a very
natural
engagement with nfts there uh because we
live so much of our digital lives
uh our lives um in a digital fashion now
that um
people are going to show collectibles
that they have that are digital
collectibles so it's kind of a natural
thing but i think because they're
digital and they are
um
derived from little programs themselves
it means that a lot more things can be
possible with them and we really plan on
exploring that um with more nfts that we
are doing um because we've already done
uh a bunch of our of our own um which
has been pretty exciting
and so we know that there are lots of
things out there that can be done
you can have like
non-fungible tokens or nfts as kind of
certificates of achievement
for you know either transcripts or that
you completed a course or or things like
that from you will from you
certifications
exactly i mean
they did that for the war from summer
school already oh yeah i remember yeah i
remember having seen that i was at the
summer camp and i saw that
i saw that that had been done at summer
school
yeah absolutely so we've been doing that
in kind of this
um fashion
that a lot of people have talked about
called live minting where you actually
um
do it
just like in a live stream which is
really exciting one for people to
be able to see
the process and see that it's something
that they can really do themselves
easily so you know people have talked
about you know smart contracts and
blockchains and all of these various
technologies it's important
uh for us to remember that
for a lot of people
um
they're intimidated by
like when you talk about programs like
even though they use programs every day
all day
when they get on their favorite social
media site or whatever um i think people
like the more they use something
the less questions they may have about
the complexity of it right um you get
kind of you know you get kind of
accustomed to it you don't really think
about what's going on underneath
yeah exactly
um so it's kind of been interesting as
we've done like workshops and other
things that people
they are really
active and want to learn how to create
their their own nfts for these kind of
certificates and i think we're going to
capitalize on that with
liveminting.com which is our site around
that kind of process and around those
tools that we've created again on the
blockchain integration work that wbl has
been doing so that's been really
exciting and i think to go back to your
original question people can not only do
these certificates
but because nfts are just programs in
and of themselves there's kind of
this there will be i think an
acceleration across lots of different
things that people do to advance i'm
just stopping myself because the things
that we are doing and experimenting with
that are really exciting but i'd rather
like hold people in a slight amount of
suspense
uh and then release it uh rather than
talk about it very strategically
yes yes yes yes
um
so those are the things that we've been
working on across the board at wbl
and again it's it's been
a really interesting time during
cobid because
i think there's been this acceleration
overall toward
people engaging in a digital life and
because blockchains themselves are
really
economic and social communities
it's kind of accelerated
their development and growth
and i think we have seen a lot of that
go on
with the different blockchain
communities that we work with and just
seeing how you know the possibilities
are really going to be
um
not only
we've not only seen a lot of things
happen
but seen a lot of possibilities for
um this upcoming
year in in 2022 and i think there'll be
a lot of more exciting stuff that we do
all right well thanks a lot for giving
us you know that pretty thorough
overview of what you've been up to i
mean i did ask a general question so it
was nice
it was nice to get all of this
information and you know learn a bit
about both blockchain uh
and about what you all have been up to
at wbl so we can kind of not use the
full mouthful phrase
yes thanks thanks it makes it way easier
and you did give me a great the actual
phrase i think for those irrigation
devices otherwise i'd be like uh
it'd be a quite comic um that's that's
my technical contribution to this
i'm sure the next person that i talk to
with an agricultural background will
appreciate that contribution
all right well thanks a lot john for
that look into what you've been up to
it's very informative for me
that was john woodard who is our ceo of
wbl or wolfram blockchain labs if you
want the full mouthful
we have a upcoming blockchain course
coming up on wolfram use so please stay
tuned for that if you're interested in
learning more about blockchains nfds and
all of this crypto related stuff
so i've been arvin calzici stay tuned
for the next tech talk
[Music]
you